à la maladie on aime bien les amis
aujourd'hui je suis malade et très
fatigués car j'ai mal dormi car je suis
malade je vous l'avais dit mec arrive à
être lourd à la 4è seconde de sa vidéo
c'est fantastique c'est un record
aujourd'hui on va tester notre cerveau
vous savez que j'aime bien mettre à
l'épreuve le savon humain le rendre
dépourvus de tout sens jeu que je suis
malade j'arrive pas à faire de belles
phrases c'est comme ça et bien
aujourd'hui j'ai trouvé un site qui
s'appelle human benchmark point com
qu'est-ce qu'un match marque les gros
geek sa mère ne savent très bien c'est
quelque chose qui teste les performances
d'un objet donné ou d'un logiciel ou
bâle par exemple tel et benchmark pour
les cartes graphiques ça permet de les
comparer entre elles pour les
processeurs etc
nous on va comparer d'entre nous nos
cerveaux qui a le plus de matière grise
donc je le fais avec la maladie on verra
si mon cerveau et garde de cette
puissance légendaires ou si du coup il
est en extinction totale ce test est
composé de quatre états bien distinctes
les unes des autres
un peu comme pour les tests de qi
finalement tu as le test où il faut
retenir des jeunes des chiffres des
épreuves de temps de réaction c'est bien
ça des épreuves ou faut retenir des
verbes et des épreuves où ces l'esat est
à mémoire visuelle saluera la mémoire
visuelle mémoire auditive est aussi la
mémoire des mouvements et ça je savais
pas c'est vous qui me l'avait appris que
voilà youtube finalement c'est quoi si
le partage mon alors number mais man et
teste les personnes normales peuvent
retenir cette nombre à la fois qu'elle
est le plus grand nombre que tu peut
mémoriser à l'ado qui veulent vraiment
ma vidéo soit ennuyante georges vraiment
devoir me concentrer et pas par les cas
les stars c'est parti sais tu as à lavit
[ __ ] cette levée l'impasse est
excellent treize 13 700 g chatel arte le
test genre tout le monde est sur un pied
d'égalité mais pas trop non plus j'ai
carrément jatte et level 421 9 allez
vas-y suivant sûr c'est bon j'ai vu
[ __ ] un verbe 731 39 suivante 634 932
à l'ego ses 134 9 50 2 634 932 là ça
commence à être dur j'étais devant je
vais commencer à ne plus parler du coup
ci je réussis suis lâchée dans la
moyenne
1987 3,70
[Musique]
au [ __ ] je suis dans la moyenne je me
sens exceptionnel 4898 28 27 4
4888 28 27 4 excellent c'est excellent
là on commence à être pas bien c'est
vrai ou pas 68 63 29 38 81 84
68 63 29 38 484 ya 46 18 81 31 62 11 46
18 81 31 62 11
46 18 81 31 62 11
pour moi jusqu'ici tout le monde y
arrive c'est à partir de maintenant
c'est le treizième chiffre qui va
prendre ton cerveau et lui mettre des
petits coups de donc respirer un grand
coup et bonne chance à tous 11 23 04 88
49 68
[Musique]
11 23 04 88 49 28
je n'ai pas fait je l'ait pas fait je me
suis emmêlé les pinceaux ma limite a été
atteinte
ok ça c'est fait le temps de réaction
mec là je suis malade je suis fatigué de
haut vol ya mon temps de réaction il est
scandaleux quoi je pense que j'ai pas le
droit de conduire tellement mon temps de
réaction est lent là quand la couleur
passe au vert clic aussi vite que tu
peux un ok c'est parti 55e
quant à sa sur un jeu vidéo tu es
tellement day of fate gers où ça souffle
c'est pas mauvais mais non si je pensais
juste comme un quart de seconde quand
même bien de la merde je suis pas partie
au quart de tour je partie au quart de
seconde sur ce malade il tente de faire
une blague et c'est le bide
incroyable allez deuxième essai je veux
faire mieux
c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien si on
fait de mieux en mieux c'est bien alors
se concentre
ah [ __ ] j'aurais grèce où on est bien
c'est dur attendez je vais fait un trio
[Musique]
à [ __ ] je suis dans le top 4 9% pour
le temps de réaction retenir des verbes
mais ça va être des verbes en anglais
moi je suis bilingue ça me dérange pas
mais pour vous excellent le mec qui se
croient billups et très bon allez c'est
parti on va te montrer des mots un par
un
si tu as vu l'un de ces mots pendant le
test appuyé sur vue si c'est un nouveau
mot appuyé sur new ok mais je
mais il est où le test fin là j'ai tout
de suite le mot je sais pas si je les ai
vus mais c'est quoi ça c'est des mots
qui sont où je comprends pas ah ok j'ai
compris le temps je suis convoqué en
fait ça ils vont tâcher plaint de maux
et les mots là qu'on vient de voir avant
objectifs vont revenir plus tard en fait
est là du coup frac et sur sin et pas
sur new look est anglaise va c'est
nouveau louvier c'est nouveau chami ces
nouveaux louzier pour l'a déjà vu spa 10
6 on n'a pas vu louzier ça va à l'essai
nous sommes nes on l'a vu et et meiser
zh
on l'a pas vu chami on l'a vu ça me
laisse arrêtés interdisent on l'a pas
vue objective on l'a vu ces premiers
napalm [ __ ] amical c'est une sorte de
message codé que le site m'envoie en
modèle est en flammes par fdp pumper
nickel c'est le mec qui pompent bien
c'est le pommeau peur ni quelle
excellente [ __ ] ingligée vu pascal japon
au base-ball j'ai vu ni cheese j'ai pas
vu nichons j'ai vu officiellement un bon
ça qui me remet le diplôme
s'il vous plaît choisi neuf fois alors
c'est quoi la moyenne jeu dans les 87 %
pour ce test
ok mémoire visuelle c'est le jeu du si -
c'est parti l' impasse mythe au jeu du
cimo a tout donné c'est parti ok les
trois cas les ivoiriens puissent de
caris trop cool c'est trop bien j'aime
trop il ya un truc dans oops et sapho
retire la séquence et la recherche merde
ça me fait beaucoup rire
waouh 1 2 1 1 1 1 1 1 1 [ __ ] c'est
chaud là bas
[Musique]
trop c'est trop
c'est fou comme mon cerveau lâche petit
à petit c'est un truc de ouf 3 un roquet
1 1
non j'ai perdu mais quel âge arrivait
plus à la fin on savait était trop
mauvais je sais plus avec la je suis
trop bien là j'arrive plus d'eau qu'on
serait qu'à environ 15 minutes de
tournage de vidéos au cerveau il est
vraiment comme ça donc je te suis plus
le cas voire du coup le score total
c'est quoi 76
eh bien je ne sais pas si c'est bien ou
pas mais je vous invite à essayer de
faire mieux à se repaître dur et bien
les amis c'est déjà la fin de cette zone
n'étaient pas des mais si elle vous a
plu et suite à ces quatre épreuves j'ai
obtenu un benchmark de voilà je vous
invite à essayer de me bats ça doit pas
être très dur vu que j'ai essayé qu'une
seule fois chaque test etc en plus
j'étais ultra nul au tout dernier
je cherche des excuses wind en avril
n'était pas le faire moi y'a un autre
site comme ça je crois c'est mon cul
point commun tous cas dans tous les
genres où c'est que des épreuves aussi
qu'ils testent un peu ton cerveau est en
fait plus tu les fais plus tard entraîne
ton cerveau je trouve ça cool de de se
muscler le cerveau voilà pour l'anecdote
je vous dis à très vite dans le projet
mme demers avoir gardé désole
aujourd'hui ce n'était pas la grande
forme c'est vraiment là la maladie dans
lé le ganglion qui est là quoi qui fait
vraiment la taille de ce pot de gel
acheté en koryttseva
j'ai certes dans la gorge c'est très
désagréable aller vers ça vous regarde
et je vous dis à bientôt une prochaine
vidéo je m'en vais dormir à les revoir
[Musique]